i
[Music] say
hello to cristian cásseres with his
brief information from news now in spanish
the las vegas metropolitan police
are investigating a fatal shooting in
the northwest valley this happened
near pena ya y govern according to
officials a man was shot and died
inside an apartment
around 2am and the gunman
fled the scene authorities
are reviewing surveillance cameras
and talking to local
residents to collect more evidence
there will be a vaccination clinic at
cashman field this will be the  friday from
4:30 to 8:30
pm if you register on the
health district page you can get two
free tickets to the
lights game if you just show up to vaccinate you
will get only one ticket
and las vegas' got dressed  gala
Thursday night when resorts world
officially opened its doors to the
public this $4.3 billion property
gave l  He
welcomed tourists and locals with a
fireworks show that they prescribed and
pottery were part of the inauguration
during the night, in addition, thousands of
people were recording inside
the facilities as soon as
the doors opened, everyone wanted to show this
new property after a decade, many
people attended and possibly a
large number are still enjoying the
place and finally we go to
the weather forecast we are back in triple digits
expect high temps with a
high of 101 degrees for friday on
saturday we will hit 104 degrees and on
sunday it will rise to 108 degrees today
cristian cásseres with his
ignis now informative preview in spanish good
morning
[Music]